[Musique]
ils sont devenus incontournables pour
collecter du renseignement éclairer un
itinéraire ou frapper l'ennemi les
drones jouent désormais un rôle majeur
sur le théâtre des opérations
aujourd'hui on estime que plus de 100
pays possèdent des drones militaires la
France on fait évidemment partie le
drone aujourd'hui c'est un gamechanger
pour les opérations c'est-à-dire c'est
la capacité pour le soldat de
s'affranchir ses obstacles face à lui à
l'heure actuelle toutes les opérations
menées dans la bande de sel au
cerhariennes se font avec un drone ce
qu'il faut retenir je pense c'est que
dans ces systèmes de drone on automatise
mais l'homme reste au centre au fil du
temps le rôle de ces machines qui ne
sont pas autonomes et dirigés à distance
a évolué et leur mission aussi doter des
dernières technologies les drones
faciles et parfois inquiète alors à quoi
sert-il réellement comment les armées
françaises les utilisent-elles et dans
quel domaine dans ce numéro inédit le
journal de la défense vous emmène à la
découverte d'un monde sous haute
surveillance un monde en perpétuel
mouvement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc le but de l'exercice pour toi ça va
être de voir la différence entre ce
qu'il y a ce qui se passe dans ta
tablette et la perception que tu en
aurais en réalité Chaumont en
Haute-Marne dans l'enceinte du 61e
régiment d'artillerie la maréchal des
logis marines restent sur ses gardes
instructrice au centre de formation
drone elle ne quitte pas son stagiaire
des yeux ni le Nano drone qui la prend à
télépiloter le black Hornet
quelque chose ils ont effectué un vol de
prise en main après ils ont fait un
exercice pour apprendre à manier un peu
les doubles commandes autour des
bâtiments plus les jours vont passer
plus les exercices vont augmenter en
difficulté
il faut dire que la prise en main du
Black Hornet est loin d'être évidente ce
minuscule hélicoptère de poche
américaine utilisée pour recueillir du
renseignement de courte portée mesure 16
cm de longueur pour seulement 33 g ok
impeccable tu peux remonter
[Applaudissements]
fais gaffe aux arbres
et tu peux aller te placer devant les
pancartes en opération ce nano drone est
principalement utilisé pour des missions
de reconnaissance aussi bien par les
forces spéciales que par les forces
conventionnelles la reconnaissance c'est
aussi la spécialité du micro drone
français NX70 développé par la PME
xoient novadem cet appareil pèse 1 kg et
dispose d'une autonomie de 40 minutes il
peut donc travailler à plus longue
distance que le black Hornet
automatique du système retour pilote
très bien
ces appareils rapides à mettre en oeuvre
joue le rôle d'éclaireur et renforce
considérablement les moyens
d'observation du combattant à l'échelle
tactique plutôt que d'aller voir un
engin explosif improvisé directement sur
position donc d'engager des moyens
humains on va préférer envoyer
éventuellement un drone donc niveau
sécurité effectivement c'est quand même
très bien et ça nous permet je vais
utiliser l'expression de plutôt que
d'escalader une colline pour aller voir
ce qui se passe derrière et bien on va
envoyer cette machine pour nous ce sera
un gain de temps et un gain d'énergie
pour nos forces
l'enfance de l'armée de terre vient dans
ce centre de Chaumont pour se former au
nano et micro drone
fantassin sapeur artilleur si à
l'origine ils ne sont pas spécialisés
dans le pilotage de drone ils viennent
chercher ici une nouvelle compétence
l'enseignement est regroupé sur cinq
jours et impose une grande concentration
cartouche ne sont pas certains de
repartir avec la précieuse qualification
il faut effectivement déjà en
premièrement réactif et des gens aptes à
restituer des savoir-faire rapidement
quelque chose qui est enseigné le matin
et souvent restitué dès l'après-midi
donc il faut des gens qui soient
vraiment motivés et intéressés par cette
par cette casquette durant cette
formation les stagiaires sont confrontés
à un maximum de situations ils
apprennent les caractéristiques
techniques et les limites de chacun
pareil afin d'être autonome une fois
déployé sur le théâtre d'opérations va
être vraiment vraiment réduit une
situation qui n'a rien de théorique dans
quelques semaines tous seront projetés
dans la bande-saelo saharienne le
nouveau segment nano micro drone a été
vraiment tiré par les opérations c'est
de l'urgence opérationnelle il s'agit de
perdre un soldats de disposer les moyens
de déceler l'ennemi dans un
environnement qui est toujours difficile
notamment la nuit c'est drôle sont le
meilleur niveau actuellement mondial ces
terres qui sont à la fois caméra
thermique caméra visible et une liaison
sol sécurisée
2019 le centre de Chaumont a réalisé 122
stages pour des formations couvrant tous
les drones de l'armée de terre cette
année le nombre de formations devrait
encore progresser cet engouement pour
les drones n'est pas une nouveauté en
France les armées ont pris en compte ce
besoin assez tôt on peut dire que il y a
eu des expérimentations
dès 1917 en France mais parallèlement
aussi aux États-Unis c'était des avions
en fait qui étaient
reconfigurés et on avait déjà une
direction à distance
et c'est en 1991 pendant la guerre du
Golfe que la France déploie pour la
première fois un drone en opération
extérieure
durant l’offensive terrestre le mini
avion de reconnaissance télépilotée le
Marthe effectue ses missions au profit
de la division d'Agay
[Applaudissements]
au fil des ans la taille la forme ou
encore l'emploi des drones a évolué et
les besoins sont toujours plus nombreux
la dotation de nos forces en système
drone est en augmentation constante ces
dernières années aujourd'hui le parc
actuel est de plusieurs centaines de
systèmes drone chiffre qui est encore
amené à accélérer dans les prochaines
années avec des exemples prévus sur les
segments nano micro mini et drone
tactique c'est ce que nous allons
constater sur le camp de Mourmelon dans
la Marne auprès de la section technique
de l'armée de terre la stats
particulières si ce n'est un Rafale qui
passera dans l'après-midi mais en
rubrifiera précisément pour sa venue
depuis plusieurs jours cette équipe
procède à l'évaluation
technicoopérationnelle du smdr le
système de mini drone de reconnaissance
le site offre une zone aérienne
suffisamment grande pour exploiter
pleinement les capacités de ce nouveau
drone de l'armée de terre
[Musique]
les tests vont porter sur la
vérification de l'autonomie du système
la vérification de la portée bien
évidemment l'industriel nous donne des
caractéristiques techniques mais
derrière il faut quand même les vérifier
il faut vérifier la capacité à mettre en
œuvre le drone dans des conditions qui
ne sont pas des conditions industrielles
c'est à dire qu'on a on est équipé
du envergure de près de 4 mètres et d'un
poids de 15 kg le smdr développé par
Thalès et surtout deux fois plus
performant que son prédécesseur le Drac
un constat adressé par l'adjudant Damon
ce chef de section minidrone formé sur
le Drac depuis plus de 10 ans est venu
apporter son expérience des opérations à
la section technique de l'armée de terre
limitée
facilement les deux heures et demie les
trois heures même alors qu'à la fin du
Drac on peiné à arriver à 45 minutes
grâce à sa liaison de données le smdr va
pouvoir transmettre en temps réel de
façon fiable et sécurisée des flux vidéo
haute définition efficaces de jour comme
de nuit
la précision de la localisation des
données un paramètre capital que
l'équipe contrôle avec minutie
utilisateurs sont les utilisateurs des
batteries
d'artillerie donc pour pouvoir tirer sur
une cible il faut que les coordonnées
soient précises pour faire du
renseignement il faut connaître la
validité du de la position aussi donc
c'est primordial de de vérifier que les
informations de coordonnées soient
exactes
pendant plusieurs semaines les
opérateurs vont étudier différents
scénarii afin de s'assurer du bon
fonctionnement du système avant son
arrivée dans les régimes
d'avoir une attention sur la zone de
récupération nous allons donc débrancher
pour
observer le comportement du drone donc
tu gardes les yeux en permanence dessus
à chaque test le système est poussé dans
ses retranchements la vigilance est donc
de mise
le drone pour se poser c'est un aéronef
et comme c'est un aéronef il a besoin de
faire un circulateur et l'idée était de
simuler un problème
un problème de liaison de données juste
avant cette phase d'atterrissage le
résultat est très bien conforme à la
documentation technique utilisateur donc
c'est pas surprise c'est très bien
la Direction générale de l'armement a
des a livré trois systèmes de mini drone
de reconnaissance à l'armée de terre 10
autres le sauront avant la fin de
l'année et ce conformément à la loi de
programmation militaire 2019-2025
[Musique]
ce drone est devenu quasi indispensable
sur les théâtres d'opération notamment
au Sahel ou plus aucune opération
d'ampleur ne se réalise sans lui
[Musique]
le Reaper est un drone mâle moyenne
altitude longue endurance c'est un
véritable avion avec des dimensions
impressionnantes 20 mètres d'envergure
pour 5 mètres de long et une masse
maximale de 5 tonnes il suffit d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui la presse pour voir les
différents succès que désormais
françaises ont réussi à atteindre ces
derniers mois en Afrique pour comprendre
que
notamment le drone IPER et les
accompagner à chaque fois
on retrouve ces drones à Cognac en
Charente sur cette base aérienne un peu
plus de 200 militaires constituent la
33e escadre de surveillance de
reconnaissance et d'attaque une
trentaine d'entre eux sont déployées en
permanence au Niger dans le cas des
opérations menées dans la bande saelo
saharienne le Reaper est utilisé depuis
2014 par l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace
les atouts de ce drone américain ne
manquent pas il est très endurant et
peut donc rester très longtemps dans le
ciel il peut aussi surveiller de larges
zones sans mettre en danger l'équipage
il permet d'effectuer des vols de
jusqu'à 24 heures de vol à des distances
pour vendre dépasser les 1000 nautiques
en 1850 km et donc c'est ce qui permet
de rester longtemps en l'air pour
obtenir le maximum de renseignements sur
l'ennemi
spécificités françaises l'équipage est
constituée de quatre personnes un pilote
un opérateur capteur un coordinateur
tactique et un opérateur image autre
spécificités ces quatre personnes sont
toujours déployées sur le terrain au
plus près des opérations pour rester
connectés avec la réalité de la
situation
le fait d'être projeté sur place vous
permet d'être psychologiquement et
concrètement vraiment disponible pour la
mission c'est à dire que vous n'avez
pendant tant que vous êtes projeté sur
le théâtre vous êtes sur une base
aérienne projetée dans un cadre quand
même particulier
sur un théâtre qui peint théâtre de
guerre mais commençait à y ressembler
fortement et vous êtes disponible pour
votre mission et sans avoir sans avoir
les aléas du quotidien qui pourrait
venir vous perturber quand ils ne sont
pas déployés les équipages multiplient
les entraînements sur la base de Cognac
et quand une mission touche à sa fin un
autre équipage débute son briefing parmi
eux la sergent Sophie opérateur image
prépare une séance de simulateur
you can seed different priority sur
pivoine in red
dans le cockpit renseignement son rôle
consiste à analyser les images radars et
les vidéos tournées par le drone
comme le reste de l'équipage elle suit
la mission en temps réel à la recherche
de la moindre information
suivez motos des véhicules ou des
personnes ça arrive à ce fréquemment et
c'est là faut noter tout ce qu'ils font
tous les différents arrêts
en 2017 la ministre des Armées Florence
Parly a décidé d'armer dans les deux ans
les drones Reaper au Sahel objectif
lutter contre les groupes armées
terroristes promesses tenues en décembre
2019 la France a procédé à ses premiers
tirs de drone armée dans le cadre de
l'opération barkhane depuis l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace a réalisé plus
d'une cinquantaine de tirs opérationnels
avec le Reaper il peut bien entendu sur
en respectant le cadre légal le strict
il peut on peut mettre en oeuvre en
toute autonomie de l'armement et donc
offrir une solution possible décideurs
d'intervenir rapidement sur par exemple
une cible à haute valeur ou alors il
peut permettre de désengager des forces
amis qui seraient pris sous le feu au
sol
raccourcir le délai entre
l’identification de la cible la prise de
décision et une éventuelle
neutralisation représente un avantage
considérable dans l'immensité de la
bande saelo saharienne ou l'opération
barkhane s'étend sur un territoire aussi
vaste que l'Europe
toutefois l'usage d'un drone ne change
rien aux règles d'usage de la force ni
au respect du droit des conflits armés
les opérateurs de drone respectent les
mêmes procédures que leurs collègues
pilote de chasse et utilisent le même
armement la montée en puissance des
drones au sein de l'armée française a
permis de bâtir de nouvelles
coopérations européennes on fait
bénéficier déjà des capacités de l'armée
de l'air à d'autres nations comme par
exemple l'Armée de l'Air espagnol qui
vient maintenant régulièrement
entretenir ses qualifications sur les
systèmes à Cognac avant de vraiment de
pouvoir utiliser les leurs de façon
vraiment
intense
la France dispose actuellement de trois
systèmes rippers un système correspond à
deux cockpites de pilotage trois drones
et un ensemble en ténèbres
le quatrième système sera livré d'ici
fin 2020 au total la France disposera de
12 drones Reaper
l'utilisation des drones a évolué en
même temps que que les technologies
c'est boucle de d'opération et de
décision et d'aide à la décision
ces raccourcis de plus en plus et avec
l'essor d'Internet aussi on avait besoin
de d'être dans ce temps de plus en plus
court et de décider rapidement c'est
moins connu mais la Marine nationale
utilise aussi des drones sur certains
navires comme ici lors d'une opération
de lutte contre la pollution en mer
après la collision de deux bateaux de
commerce ces images prises par un mini
drone ont permis de localiser les nappes
de polluants et de les pomper dans les
plus brefs délais
si les marins attendent l'arrivée
prochaine de minidron de 15 à 20 kg un
autre dispositif fait déjà parlé de lui
le dam le système de drone aérien pour
la marine
ambitieux est au cœur des discussions
entre l'ingénieur en chef de l'armement
Cyril et le capitaine de frégate
Jean-Michel sur le sujet donc les
différents éléments qui vont être qui
vont être importants de regarder
ensemble ça va être l'intégration des
deux charges utiles avec les deux
options possibles l'objectif de ce
projet consiste à développer un drone
tactique pour étendre les capacités de
surveillance et de détection du navire
porteur le dame conçu sur la base d'un
hélicoptère sera doté de 10 heures
d'autonomie et pourra opérer jusqu'à 185
km du bâtiment ce programme se trouve
dans sa phase de préparation c'est à
dire c'est une phase pendant laquelle
nous allons définir les caractéristiques
et les performances du futur système et
donc pour ce faire la DGA la Direction
générale de l'armement a placé un
contrat en 2017 à Airbus hélicoptère et
naval Group dont le but
identifier et de développer les
technologies clés qui seront nécessaires
pour répondre aux besoins de la marine
donc dans ce cadre là nous avons
contractualisé la réalisation d'un
démonstrateur et qui réalisera une
campagne d'essai en mer en 2021 sur une
frame de la marine
une étape cruciale car c'est à ce
moment-là que sera validé la capacité
d'appontage en automatique de ce drone
qui pèsera entre 700 et 800 kg toute
cette préparation de la campagne de 2021
va être basée sur une logique de
validation progressive on va faire
d'abord atterrir le slam le prototype à
terre puis sur une plateforme mobile
puis sur un pont qui va simuler les
mouvements d'une frégate avant d'aller
se poser en mer sur une vraie frame
c'est un travail très collaboratif on
travaille en équipe intégrée c'est à
dire qu'on mêle l'expertise technique de
la DGA avec l'expérience opérationnelle
des forces le dam sera utilisé en
complément des hélicoptères de la marine
sur les frégates de premier rang mais
également sur les portes hélicoptères
amphibie puis plus tard sur les
patrouilleurs océaniques
c'est un défi technologique majeur donc
c'est stimulant personnellement
individuellement et c'est également un
défi opérationnel qui est qui est
primordial pour conférer à nos forces
une capacité opérationnelle qui puisse
utiliser tous les jours y compris
lorsque la mer n'est pas belle donc les
contraintes d'environnement sont bien
des défis à part entière la pontage en
fait partie on a également la
compatibilité électromagnétique puisque
un bâtiment de combat concentre en son
sein nombreux émetteurs très variés et
de puissance très différentes il faudra
que le drone puisse s'intégrer de
manière naturelle dans l'activité du
bâtiment
un défi de taille qui va connaître un
coup d'accélérateur dans le cadre du
plan de relance aéronautique de juin
2020 un deuxième système de
démonstration sera produit il permettra
à la marine d'approfondir ses
expérimentations
[Musique]
la Marine nationale ne mise pas que sur
les drones aérien elle suit avec
beaucoup d'attention le projet MMCM
développé dans le cadre du système de
lutte anti-mines du futur le slamèche ce
système prépare le renouvellement de la
capacité de guerre des mines avec
l'emploi de drones sous-marins et de
surface
lancer en 2010 dans le cadre du traité
de Lancaster House entre la France et le
Royaume-Uni et placée sous l'égide de
l'organisation conjointe de coopération
en matière d'armement le projet MMCM de
développement des prototypes de drone a
été attribué en 2015 un consortium
franco-britannique emmené par Thalès
son programme consiste à développer la
guerre des mines du futur sur la base de
drones et de d'engins complètement
autonomes
donc on va trouver un drone de surface
par exemple qui va être contrôlé à
partir d'un centre de commandement qu'on
peut voir juste ici ou un drone
sous-marin
ce drôle de surface permet également de
déployer soit un sonar tracté pour faire
ce qu'on appelle de la détection
classification localisation des objets
posés sur le fond et potentiellement des
mines et ensuite de débarquer ce son art
tracté pour mettre un véhicule
philoguidé qui permet d'aller
identifier si effectivement c'est une
mine ou pas et éventuellement de la
neutraliser donc ce programme a démarré
en mars 2015 avec des partenaires qui
s'appelle SAB que donc c'est une société
suédoise pour le véhicule philoguidé et
qu'à la société de Toulon spécialiste en
robotique pour les drones sous-marins et
ASV L3 à risque qui est la société qui
produit les drones de surface
à nouveau l'objectif est bien d'éloigner
l'homme de la zone de danger grâce
notamment à la capacité augmentée du
dispositif ce drone sous-marin pourra
par exemple aller jusqu'à 300 mètres de
fond
[Musique]
la programmation la planification et le
suivi des missions s'effectuera à partir
d'un poste de commandement comme
celui-ci situé jusqu'à 20-25 km de
distance
[Musique]
c'est centre correspond à la fois à la
passerelle d'un bâtiment et à son centre
opérationnel ces trois opérateurs
peuvent par exemple aujourd'hui faire
une mission avec le drone de surface
donc c'est l'opérateur qui se trouve à
ma gauche
il peut également y avoir un autre
opérateur qui va gérer les drones
sous-marins et enfin un dernier
opérateur qui est ici qui lui va traiter
les données du sonar dans ce container
hautement sécurisé capable de traiter
des données secret défense les
opérateurs vont pouvoir s'appuyer sur
l'intelligence artificielle
on a une base de données et la base de
données utilise des des opérations
d'intelligence artificielle pour dire à
l'opérateur cet objet est très
probablement de type mine X ou Y et ça
ça l'aide énormément
ce PC et tous les systèmes y compris le
drone de surface de 12 mètres ont été
conçus pour embarquer dans un A400M afin
d'être déployé en 48 heures sur un
théâtre d'opérations un gain de temps
considérable quand on sait qu'il faut
une quinzaine de jours aujourd'hui à un
chasseur de minuterie parti pour
réaliser cette opération
ce sont ces bâtiments que le programme
slamef va remplacer dans la guerre des
minins ce que va faire le slamev c'est
notamment pour la pour les fonctions
militaires c'est surveiller en
permanence les accès de Brest de Toulon
pour s'assurer que tous les bâtiments
militaires et notamment la dissuasion
puisse continuer à agir c'est s'assurer
également pour le pour en métropole dans
nos ports métropolitains que tous les
approvisionnements de commerce qui
arrivent au Havre à Marseille et je
pourrais essayer tous les autres pornos
continue et c'est aussi plus loin plus
loin de nos côtes mais aussi des
intérêts stratégiques pour nous c'est
s'assurer que nos que la libre
navigation le trafic commercial puisse
continuer à passer que ce soit sur des
endroits aussi stratégiques que Babel
Mendes ou encore plus loin Malacca Suez
car contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser la mine n'avale est toujours un
problème d'actualité tous les ans ce
sont entre 30 et 40 tonnes de munitions
qui sont détruites le long des côtes
françaises et on estime qu'un million de
mines seraient détenus dans les stocks
d'armement mondiaux
s'adapter à cette menace et donc
nécessaire même si cela doit occasionner
une transformation profonde faut changer
notre manière de former le personnel il
faut changer nos modèles de ressources
humaines il faut changer nos doctrines
nos manières d'opérer parce que c'est
peut-être c'est pas toujours forcément
intuitif pour des gens qui ne sont pas
accultura à ce niveau là mais en passant
d'un système comme le chasseur de mines
où en fait vous regardez devant vous un
système avec les drones où vous regardez
sur les côtés et en étant proche du fond
et ben je n'irai pas que tous s'effondre
mais en tout cas une bonne partie de nos
acquis théoriques sont à sont à revoir
une nouvelle histoire à écrire donc où
le marin restera un personnage central
dans le cadre du programme slames quatre
systèmes de drone antimine seront livrés
d'ici la fin de la loi de programmation
militaire 2019-2025
comme dans le monde civil l'utilisation
des drones est appelée à se démocratiser
au sein des armées
certains drones commerciaux sont
utilisés par les forces par la
gendarmerie de l'air à Orléans par
exemple
[Musique]
on voit la présence au niveau du
grillage deux personnels
ce drone français fabriqué par la
société Parrot contribue à la protection
des emprises militaires ça nous permet
vraiment de d'accélérer et d'augmenter
notre notre rayon d'action au niveau de
la surveillance des bases aériennes
ensuite ça nous permet aussi donc de
récupérer des vidéos des images et de
pouvoir les transmettre immédiatement
notre hiérarchie par exemple en cas de
crash
aériennes seront équipées de ces petits
aéronefs de plus en plus sophistiqués
les drones ont vu leur usage exploser
pour le compte du ministère des armées
la Direction générale de l'armement
effectue une veille permanente pour se
tenir informée des nouveaux modèles qui
arrivent sur le marché disposez des
compétences clés sur ce secteur est un
gage de souveraineté et l'innovation est
une nécessité pour éviter de tout des
classements il est donc primordial de
surveiller ces innovations de les
soutenir pour que me force puisse en
bénéficier car demain se prépare
aujourd'hui
ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui c'est
pouvoir donner au drone des capacités
nouvelles notations de taper
électronique aller repérer l'ennemi non
pas simplement parce qu'on le voit mais
parce qu'il aimait des ondes et ces
ondes émises par l'ennemi sont de nature
à le localiser donc il faut aller
chercher ce genre de renseignement mais
non nous voulons aussi utiliser le drone
comme relais radio dans des grands
espaces comme la branche de sarienne
mais aussi un espace coupé comme les
zones urbaines ou les communication
passe mal de son côté l'armée de l'Air
et de l'Espace qui opère déjà sur
l'ensemble des catégories de drones
poursuit ses essais consistant à faire
inspecter des aéronefs par des drones
elle travaille aussi sur des engins
capables de porter différentes charges
et sur bien d'autres projets en lien
avec l'actualité de ces derniers mois je
vois bien que cette crise du covid
aujourd'hui qui a d'énormes besoins
notamment pour les drones d'avoir des
objets qui puissent nous permettre de
faire de la détection de zone
contaminées même par le virus sur des
des grandes surfaces et d'intervention
notamment de désinfection
pour préparer le retour de
l'installation à un usage un usage
normal ou le retour du personnel nous
avons aussi des projets de beaucoup plus
long terme qui sont ce qu'on appelle les
drones Halles donc haute altitude longue
endurance qui sont en fait
l'étape intermédiaire avant le satellite
donc ce sont des objets qui restent très
très haut pendant des semaines voire des
mois en l'air
enfin l'armée de terre sera à l'avenir
doté de drone tactiques pas trop leur le
travail sur les drones qui
accompagneront le SCAF le système de
combat aérien du futur est lancé et les
discussions sont en cours autour du
drone européen entre la France
l'Allemagne l'Italie l'Espagne et les
industriels autant d'exemples qui
démontrent que l'air des drones et
durablement engagé